I just put business in perspective to
put things in perspective keep things in
perspective keep things in perspective
keep perspective have a different
perspective
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can keep things in
perspective and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really inspires you please leave it down
in the comments below put quotes around
it as well so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to sink into yourself
as well enjoy when you have a down time
like if something didn't hear the way
you want what you do to get back on that
positive I talked to the mountain I have
a mountain next to my home that is
called Washington a it goes up to - it's
very low goes up to 2000 oh I talked to
the dome DVD which is 4,000 meters which
is really the further away from my house
which I see every morning I see those
two mountains and I say to these two
mountains mountains I have a problem but
when I look at you you are 37 million
[Laughter]
strong little guy here will be little
problem can you help me they will say
come on look what we have already seen
it so many years the whole problem is
the Nano problem come on get up just get
up do it that's it and make wishes
I'm entrepreneur it's very great but not
all days are great in a company so are
your tips and tricks for you
days I think there's massive confusion
around entrepreneurship entrepreneurship
sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right or a girlfriend
right like like it's there's a ton of
bad days being an entrepreneur
not to mention 98% of entrepreneurial
ventures are gonna fail so there's gonna
be a really bad day in your future you
know hopefully not for you or any of you
you know for me I don't you know I think
this is a very personal question I think
it's how you're wired I'm so all-in
entrepreneur I prefer the pain I think
one of the reasons I love the jet so
much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I I love the climb to me
the setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it could be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things it can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I could make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most that it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put in perspective it's money and
you know what up until I had a daughter
even while I was married up until when I
had Nisha four years ago I secretly
wanted to lose all my money I had this
weird twisted dark fantasy of losing
everything just to rise
again like a Phoenix and reminding me do
you feel underrated as a rapper not as
of lately like which is crazy for a long
time and for years I was pissed so a
song on the album called buried alive is
it's about that exactly you know it's
about like me kind of going how come he
gets this so-and-so cosign or how come
he gets that or how come they get that I
can tour the world I can sell out shows
I got fans I got this with man like
being angry you know I had a friend tell
me she basically said those same people
who have the cosines and have this and
have the looks are the same people are
going how come I got fans like this dude
how come I can't tell where on my own
how come I can't dislike what the so
kind of put things in perspective for me
and let me go okay I don't have it yet
but if I keep fighting I keep working
hard and I keep staying on this path
it's gonna happen you know and as of
late was in the last few months man just
from you know like releasing the singles
and the music videos and like this solid
body of work I've truly began to get
what I deserve 13 years ago you were
completely bust gone no money you had
five pounds of seven dollars left in
your hand you use it for a taxi back to
your parents and your career in a record
business had just come to a sudden
shuddering halt and here you are 13
years later worth hundreds of millions
of dollars life's taken a huge turn up
as but I get the sense with you there
what happened to you 13 years ago still
defines you now yeah I mean it wasn't
the best of times but and then again and
when I look back on it it wasn't the
worst of times you know Biggers I I
think particularly here in in Hollywood
where where most people get it wrong is
they're afraid of losing what they've
got
they're just terrified of losing their
fame that you said power money but
actually once you've lost it you can
always get it back again then when it's
not the end of the world I mean being
ills worse so because I've actually
faced one of most people's worst fears
and recovered from it it's not as bad as
you think you know I didn't lose my
confidence my friends were still my
friends I've lived with my parents and I
just saw as a challenge that I've got to
get myself back on my feet again what
advice to parents give you them
they were really you know honest to God
they were just cool about it you know
they were parents they just you know
want to look after me live with them for
a while my dad left me some money to pay
the bank then eventually managed to pay
my dad back you know it was what any
parent would do but like I said it's it
wasn't it wasn't the worst time of my
life and actually when I look back on it
now I still smile because you know I
bought this beat-up old British sports
car worked 18 hours a day and I'm so
determined piers just to get it right
this time
because I knew why I got it wrong so now
I find it much easier to deal with
things if that wasn't the worst time in
your life what was when my dad died was
the worst time in my life as you know
you know disgust that it was just that
you know like getting ill losing a
parent or losing a you know somebody
close to you that's the worst thing that
could ever happen in your life you know
all the things that I worry about now
which is trivial I mean you know even
the whole kind of Idol x-factor thing I
laugh about it because it's such a
high-class problem my show is better
than your show is like we're both we
both got a show Colin Firth and Hugh
Grant and the Fountain Inn Bridget Jones
is that quite exact over what I've made
the fact that we're here we can do this
it's fantastic before every one of my
debates I did something to keep things
in perspective to keep myself grounded
at the top of a sheet of paper that was
always placed on the podium so we could
make notes during the debate just before
the debate kicked off I wrote at the top
one word dad I also drew a small image
of the son and throughout the debate
when I glanced down at that paper to
look at my notes that I'd taken I was
reminded of my father's fearlessness in
fighting for what he believed was right
and the son that reminded me of course
of that familiar scripture lets your
light so shine we don't lose that debate
I hoped I would never do anything that
would dishonor or discredit the things I
hold most dear now during your life
you're going to encounter circumstances
that make you sweat
for many of you the exams and tests
won't be over when you graduate and
you're all gonna stand at podiums stand
in front of a boss to ask for a raise or
work on some critical project in your
employment that'll make a big difference
in your life at moments like those
perspective is a very powerful friend
you can welcome perspective through
preparatory prayer by considering the
blessings of the temple or by simply
glancing at your CTR ring find ways to
keep your life in perspective when I was
20 I worked for the group Malvern in New
York I work for the Sanitation
Department I was a garbage man you will
recover how's the garbage man I worked
the back of the truck 22 square blocks
that's hard doing movies isn't there's
nothing that we do in the movies and I'm
supposed to build over four United
Parcel Service yeah truck alright that
was hard yeah yeah this is a joke Ted
yeah do you think we say why do you
spend so much time preparing and
everything cuz it's a bunch of other
other guys out there that would want my
job and I'm not gonna do anything to
mess it up that's right keep things in
perspective I know we all say it but it
really used to have to keep reinforcing
it you know all of everyone in this in
this audience you know knock on wood
you're gonna do just fine
you're gonna have your four-bedroom
house you're gonna have your car with
with power windows you'll be able to go
to SeaWorld whenever you want to and but
but along that way they're gonna be ups
and downs and actually those ups and
downs tend to happen a lot when you go
to transition points when you you're
entering the workforce you're entering
some type of a new phase in your life
and and you just always have to keep on
the kind of the long-term game the end
game and you know I'll tell you myself
I've gone through some fairly dramatic
ones right when I was out the gate you
know when I was this is 1998 I just
graduated I was a few months older than
most of y'all and some computer magazine
had seen something I had done and they
wrote this you know this neat profile
about me they say they call it future so
bright and and I
that man was very proud of it I said God
look I'm set you know I have I I have
this career ahead of me I'm already
profiled in a magazine and and frankly I
got kind of kind of into myself and and
that's okay you can enjoy your successes
but I had really didn't have any
perspective and and and and it frankly
it was it was a dangerous thing to
happen and and to really put things in
perspective and I'm happy it did happen
two months later I had kind of switched
jobs and you know higher salary I
thought I was on the fast track and I
had a new boss and on the first three
days of work he spent an hour just
completely castigating me essentially
telling me that I was not worth his time
that I I I was incompetent as far as he
was concerned and so you can imagine you
know like a lot of is successful whole
life fancy degrees from fancy
universities two months ago I was
profiled in a magazine and and then now
all of a sudden not even not almost not
even 23 years old I was back in a hotel
room in the middle of nowhere crime not
knowing what I was going to do with my
life convinced that it was all the end
of everything that all everything was
for naught and you know saw you get
through them you wake up in the morning
things look a little bit better a week
later things look a little better you
start circulating your resume around I
did find another job two months later
and and it's okay and and and the one
thing I want to stress because you know
I've gone through ups and downs and you
only have one perspective for your own
life but I suspect many of y'all are
going to have higher ups than I've had
and many are gonna have higher lower
downs and I and I and I worry about that
sometimes the ones of you who have
higher ups just keep them in perspective
and it's inevitable so you're gonna race
ahead and be so successful that none of
us can imagine it right now but keep
them in perspective you know when you
want to enjoy the successes but when you
know when your ego starts feeling a
little bit large keep in mind the Sun
will supernova one day the galaxies will
collide we are see small little mammals
on this small planet or you know there's
a hundred two hundred billion stars in
the galaxy and just our galaxy alone and
and and and just have peace and in the
little success and when you have a hard
time and you will and those are go
through painful periods you
you you you might stumble and start your
first few times out the gate also keep
in perspective that those stresses put
them in perspective of the universe they
are small they're going to be things
that you'll be able to laugh about talk
about a 10 15 years from now or
hopefully ten fifteen days from then
keep perspective and that's the hardest
thing to tell somebody when they're
going through a hard time because you
know it's so easy to say well you don't
understand me or this is so hard or this
is the worst time in my life and and
some of that might feel true and it
might be true it might be one of the
most difficult trying times of your life
and all we can say is keep perspective
we can't say keep perspective other than
just say you know there have been good
times remember them don't cut loose of
those good times in your memories just
because now your focus is on the dark
times remember those times that were
better remember those times in which you
did connect with others that you did
create that you did take action and
remember also your strength because it's
so easy when the times are dark to just
focus on all the things that you're
doing to screw it up or all the things
that people are doing to mess with your
life and you forget the incredible power
that you have I mean it is an amazing
miracle if you're looking for the
miracle you already got it that miracle
that you've been given the power of
choice and will to direct your own
attention each day to direct your own
attitude each day to direct your own
actions each day to direct your own
affections and emotions out into the
world that you control those things that
you can move those things that you can
shape those things that's the miracle
you are the miracle you've been waiting
for something to show up and change and
I just say you've already been given the
gift now you have to activate it
so when it's difficult keep perspective
on the fact that there have been good
times there will be more good times that
even if you are struggling personally
you still have that great freedom that
has been given to us and that that
choice that gift of free will to start
directing yourself I mean obviously you
can't come on a show like this without
mention of the wanking in the toilet
thing
in the toilet they which one be arrested
Oh rascals
that one yeah the one that worried about
time I got caught you
the way you talk about is it your
fantastic sort of unapologetic versus
and you didn't go into hiding you didn't
you know sort of go you know draw the
curtains like that was it the next night
you were out in a restaurant in LA
having dinner
absolutely well I mean what's to
apologize for you know I'm a gay man I'm
at the time I was like 36 years old if
I'm perfectly honest if I'm perfectly
perfectly honest outside of my career
I've had a terrible run of luck that
started about 10 years ago I've I've
watched a partner die I've watched my
mother die I went just after that I had
I went to see a as a back surgeon who
told me that if I didn't have two
vertebra removed within the next six
months to year that I could paralyzed so
you just had learned have a different
perspective I don't give a toss if
people have a real problem with me you
know having
[Applause]
I have a different perspective on life I
lost a lot of great things but I still
have a lot of incredible things and the
press doesn't really enter into it I
want my daughter Arabella to grow up
thinking that the phrase working woman
sounds as odd and superficial and forced
as the phrase working man my husband is
my greatest source of motivation she
always has it in her to accomplish
whatever she puts her mind to he's the
person I mean on the most
I always telephone good don't worry
about the things you can't control just
worry about how you react to and deal
with the circumstances and situations at
hands in the moments of highest anxiety
for me I will think about Jared and the
kids and realize that no matter how
poorly I perform I will come home that
night
and my kids will not love me any less
and my husband will love me just as much
maybe even a little bit more because I
don't know I'll need it cut outcomes the
way to see the fact that she doesn't
work her oh thank you guys so much for
watching
I'd love to know what did you think of
this video what lesson did you learn
that you love the most about this how do
you keep things in perspective for
yourself leave it down the comments
below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to tech OSHA Swann thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon